elizabeth warren's wealth tax is a full
scale disaster Bernie campaigns with a
ocn Democrats open up those public
impeachment hearings i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show the ben
shapiro show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights visit
expressvpn comm slash men they really
are great check them out expressvpn comm
slash Ben okay well I have a lot to get
to today we're gonna be talking about
the latest interviews from MK but I
really do want to talk about this attack
on a billionaires who the evil
billionaires we'll get to that in just
one second first if you're looking at
the way that the left is attacking free
market capitalism right now if you're
looking at the way that the left is
attacking lays a fair and your ability
to keep your own wealth and your
thinking okay if Elizabeth Warren
becomes the the President of the United
States god forbid you're just gonna
start playing around with all the
mechanisms that allow wealth to grow
maybe you're thinking maybe I shouldn't
invest in the US dollar right now
maybe I should invest instead in
something a little bit more solid like
gold well a lot of other people are
thinking the same thing gold is right
now sitting at its five-year high I've
been telling you for years that gold is
a safe haven against uncertainty and
chaos in the markets well Democrats are
certainly going to exacerbate all of
that this is why you should try out
Birch gold Birch gold we'll go to work
and make things simple they'll have a
conversation with you you can determine
if precious metals make sense to include
in your portfolio again it makes sense
for my portfolio you should be a
diversified at least a little I'm not
talking liquidate all your assets and
buy bars of gold I'm talking take some
of your money put it in precious metals
it helps balance out your portfolio
I trust the folks at Birch gold I'm
working with them for years if I didn't
trust them I wouldn't work with them
texts been to 47 47 47 today to see how
simple and straightforward a move into
precious metals can be for you again
that is been to 47 47 47 when he speaks
to them be sure to ask what promotions
they're currently offering text my name
Ben - 47 47 47 okay so the the ramping
up of a tax on wealth in this country
it's it's happening an extraordinary
rate and it starts off as these attacks
on quote unquote billionaires and then
pretty soon the left realizes that
there's not enough money with the
billionaires to just attack the
billionaires then it turns into an
attack on millionaires then pretty soon
it turns into an attack on people who
make more than 500 thousand dollars a
year then pretty soon it turns into
attack on people who make more than
twenty two hundred thousand dollars a
year what you will see is that the bar
for becoming rich
in this country is going to continue to
decline now obviously if you're a
billionaire a millionaire something
making half a million bucks a year
you're doing fine
but the fact is that to support the kind
of social spending that Democrats want
to support the kind of market
regulations the Democrats want tax rates
don't just have to be high on wealthy
people they have to be exorbitant on
people who are middle-class which is why
if you go over to all the Scandinavian
countries that the left loves to cite as
socialist havens even though they are
capitalist countries with heavy social
safety nets if you go over to Norway if
you go over to Denmark if you go over to
any of the places that the left truly
loves massive middle-class tax rates
high middle-class tax rates now Bernie
Sanders will tell you this Elizabeth
Warren Wilmot and Elizabeth Warren is
getting away with lying about all of
this by talking about her so-called
wealth tax well she's just going to
attack tax the people who are the
billionaires it's gonna be the
billionaire's tax people who are worth
fifty million dollars and more those
people are going to experience a wealth
tax and if you look at the polls this
polls pretty well why well because the
natural human instinct is to say well
those people have enough money what's
the big deal if we just take all their
money if we just take more and more of
it and it's not all their money it's 2%
of their wealth every year why is that a
big deal well right now I want to
explain to you why all of that is a big
deal and why this is a very stupid idea
why it's an unworkable idea why it's a
counterproductive idea well actually
hurt the economy for you not just for
billionaires not just for people who are
very wealthy but for you because the
fact is that tax policy is intimately
involved with the future growth of the
United States economy now the left seems
to think that you can just run into
wealthy people's houses steal all their
stuff and that this will like every year
do it and that this is not gonna have
any impact on the American economy or
the global economy on investment rates
on tax avoidance they don't seem to
understand the elasticity and markets
that when you think that when you change
the incentive structure for people their
behavior also changes that if you seize
wealth from people the way that they
behave changes the way they invest
changes and that has impacts that ripple
out beyond whether Bill Gates can buy
his 100th car and they seem to believe
that you can just confiscate wealth and
that wealthy people will act exactly the
same that it doesn't change the nature
of the economy at all it's a fixed pie
so if we just grabbed more from the rich
people what's the big deal how does that
affect anything okay well let's go
through the wealth tax and let's talk
about Elizabeth Warren's proposal which
by the way he used to be 2% per year the
wealth tax but then when she made her
Medicare for all proposed
she ramped that up to I believe six
percent per year in wealth tax so first
of all let's distinguish a wealth tax
from other kinds of tax an income tax is
based on the amount of income you make I
get a salary I make a certain amount of
income I have a business I take a
certain amount of income and now I pay a
certain amount of tax on that income
right there's graduated income tax rates
once you get to the top tax rates you're
paying something like thirty five
percent in top tax if you're in the
state of California playing thirty five
percent plus twelve percent to the top
tax rate so you're paying a lot of money
you're paying a lot of money and the
talk of how people at the top of the
income tax bracket are not paying a lot
of money is just a lie okay the idea
that rich people are not paying their
fair share is absolutely untrue Richard
Epstein who is a law professor over at
University of Chicago and he also is a
rights for the Hoover Institute he says
the fraction of total tax is paid by the
ninety percent of the population has
shrunk over the last 35 years the bottom
ninety percent of the population so you
keep hearing that it's the middle class
burying the burden of taxes these days
absolutely false
complete lie ninety percent of the
population in their tax burden has
shrunk over the past thirty five years
from about fifty percent of the total
tax burden it's about thirty five
percent that means ninety percent of the
population is paying thirty five percent
of the total tax currently about 40
percent of all total taxes are paid by
the top one percent is those one
percenters those evil one percenters
they are supporting four in ten tax
dollars four in ten top 1% and say well
maybe they have all the income they
don't okay they're earning about 20
percent of the income so they don't 20%
of the income the top one percent and
they pay 40% of the total tax burden if
you pile on top of that a massive wealth
tax that's a pretty big deal especially
because when you're talking about taxing
wealth you're not talking about taxing
income okay the the first of all there's
this this lie that has to be debunked
very quickly which is that the people at
the top are getting very wealthy and
everybody else is getting poorer and
this is not true as a manual it's a is
in gabriel zucman who are elizabeth
warren's basically official economist
and they're not very good at their jobs
point out the yearly increase in wealth
for the top 0.1% between 1980 and 2016
has averaged about five point three
percent but the general average in the
United States is two point five percent
so everybody has been increasing it's
just the people at the very top have
been increasing than people lower down
okay so the question becomes
why is that innately a horrible thing
alright just because somebody is doing
better than you doesn't mean that you
are doing poorly stop looking over your
shoulder at the guy who lives next door
as I've said before if you own the
mansion next door to Bill Gates there's
a tremendous amount of income inequality
between you and Bill Gates but you're
still living a pretty good life I'm
you're living next door to Bill Gates I
assume you're not living in a box right
probably living in a very nice house
right next to Bill Gates okay so the
difference you know wealth tax and the
and the income tax is that the income
tax is measured by your income a wealth
tax takes your entire asset base and
then forces you to have that assessed
every single year and then they take 2%
of your wealth base so let's say that
you are a business owner you're not
somebody who has cashed out your
businesses and you just have stalked
your business owner okay in your
business you it's an 80 million dollar
business and you're the sole owner of
that 80 million dollar business now does
that mean that you're making 80 million
dollars a year from that business no it
absolutely does not it absolutely does
not right because the fact is that if
you own a business the vast majority of
the money in your business is poured
back into running the business but let's
say that you own a business that is
valued at 80 million dollars how would
you value that well maybe you value it
by using a three times EBIT done right
earnings before interest tax and
interest in taxes right let's say that
you you value it that way and let's say
then now that is assessed it at eighty
million dollars well now you're gonna
have to pay presumably two percent of
that amount so you're paying let's see
one point six million dollars one point
six million dollars to taxes that could
be your entire profit margin on that
business right there you're paying
because again you're valuing the wealth
and then you are taxing the wealth okay
that's very different from you have a
certain amount of stock and the stock is
publicly traded and we know how much
that is worth and so we forced you to
liquidate some of that stock even that
is a bad idea
because again you haven't sold the stock
you didn't realize the gain you haven't
realized the loss so imagine for a
second that you have tons and tons of
stock and let's say that it's 2008 and
the stock market has just plummeted you
haven't actually realized the value of
the stock right you've taken a hit but
you haven't actually sold right Warren
Buffett wasn't was once asked how much
money did you lose during the Great
Recession and he said in lose any
because I didn't sell my stock right
it's only a loss that has realized when
you sell your stock but according to the
wealth tax every single year Warren
Buffett's stock would have to be valued
and then you
take a portion of that value and you
would assess that as a tax even though
he has not actually sold the stock but
he's not actually realized any gain from
the stock it's just sitting there but
every single year they would take a
percentage of that value okay how about
your property your property would be
reassessed every single year and then
but by what Zillow and then you would
have to pay a percentage of what that
property is worth 2% per year
his same thing would go true for all of
your other stuff right would it be true
for let's say you own a painting let's
he owned a you own the Mona Lisa and
it's worth 50 million dollars or is it
worth 100 million dollars who knows
because it the upper end of the art
market there's a tremendous amount of
vagary in terms of what things are worth
after all there aren't that many buyers
at the upper end of the market so it
could be worth 50 it could be a hundred
million dollars well that's a pretty
significant difference in terms of what
you're paying in tax the cost of
compliance on this sort of thing are
extraordinary this is why the estate tax
which by the way is immoral the estate
tax is immoral the reason that it is
immoral is because you paid taxes on
this stuff your entire life and just
because you died and hand it to your
kids which was the purpose of you
handing wealth
now the government prized open your safe
and just takes your money they walk over
your dead body to take your money so
your kids can't have it even though you
pay taxes on that income your entire
life Elizabeth Warren is doing the same
thing it's confiscatory right you pay
taxes on all of this income your entire
you paid 35 40 percent taxes alright I
pay very high tax rates at a certain
point presumably I won't be running this
business anymore right I'll retire and
then I don't have to pay taxes again for
the sin of what having run the business
and paid taxes for years and years and
years on end on a basic moral level this
is immoral but an effective level it's
also stupid the reason that it's stupid
is because you know how much it takes to
actually do the compliance with a twith
a liquidated wealth tax this way you
have to have every value item that you
have assessed every single year now in
the case of the estate tax maybe that
makes sense at least then the estate
taxes are too like up to 40% so the
government is making a bunch of money so
it makes sense to force you to do all
that stuff but for a 2% total as Warren
is proposing the amount of compliance
that the IRS would have to check would
probably cost more than the amount of
money that they would get from the tax
itself this is what Richard Epstein
points out he says the administrative
cost of imposing a 2% wealth tax on
persons whose net worth is say 55
million dollars would surely surpass the
$100,000 the tax would generate just to
me
how much will cost the IRS to process
75,000 tax returns that size and zucman
predict will be filed annually
also as Epstein points out when you are
very wealthy and then you don't take
that money and you don't invest it
because why would you possibly invest it
because they're just going to assess you
and then they're going to take money
away from you so why wouldn't just leave
it in cash presumably or stock it in
overseas assets or move overseas
altogether this would have an impact on
GDP it would have an impact you're gonna
force people to liquidate their
businesses you're gonna force people to
sell their businesses this happened in
France rich people were forced to sell
their businesses because the profit
margin they were making from the
business was not enough to outstrip the
actual tax that they were paying from
the business so instead they sell the
business or let's say that you have a
stock let's say that you're Jeff Bezos
and you own a ton of Amazon stock and
every year you're gonna be forced to
liquidate two percent two billion
dollars worth of your stock for example
so you sell it on the open market
because you have to liquidate it to pay
the tax what do you think that does to
the price of the stock you are now
flooding the market with Amazon stock
what do you think that does to the
Amazon stock it sends it down you've now
increased the supply without increasing
the demand for the stock so what exactly
are you doing you're you're lowering the
price well a lot it turns out Jeff Bezos
isn't the only investor in Amazon guys
it turns out there a lot of 401ks tied
up in the stock market as Richard
Epstein points out a 1% decline in GDP
of two hundred billion dollars could
largely wipe out the suppose at revenue
gain of the wealth tax most rich people
do not idly count their wealth sitting
under palm trees they continue to
reinvest it in new projects that require
both equity and debt capital when a
wealth tax of five or ten million
dollars comes to it could require an
entrepreneur to liquidate part of his
business or to divert his assets from
investment and business growth to the
payment of taxes and guys this isn't
speculative I'm gonna give you
real-world examples in a second of how
the wealth tax has actually been a giant
fail before we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about
something sweeter something that
everybody likes okay this is something
everybody likes billionaires
millionaires people who are not earning
that much money everybody likes cookies
they are the best right okay so this is
the easiest sell of all time the
holidays are coming up and that means it
is time for mrs. Fields Cookies when
Debbie Fields started mrs. Fields
Cookies 40 years ago she went over
cookie lovers everywhere at the gooey
chocolate chip cookies
melt-in-your-mouth brownies passion for
sharing the joy of baked goods mrs.
Fields I managed solid stuff nowadays
you can have the cookie Center right
where you want them without viz
a bakery which is amazing I mean you
don't have to even leave your house and
suddenly you've got this amazing stuff
just arriving at your door with gourmet
gift tins and baskets filled with
fresh-baked cookies you know that your
order will arrive fresh and flavorful
ordering is easy they can ship your
cookies anywhere across the country and
if you are ordering as a gift which you
should you can add a personal custom
message company logo or family photo
best of all mrs. fields offers a 100%
customer satisfaction guarantee you know
why they can do that because 100% of
their customers are basically satisfied
if you are not satisfied by mrs. field
cookie you're Stalin I don't want to
tell you mrs. Fields Cookies are the
best to sweeten the deal our listeners
get 20% off your entire order when you
go to mrs. Fields calm and enter promo
code Shapiro that is 20% off any gift at
mrs. fields calm promo code Shapiro mrs.
Fields compro moko Chihiro your cookies
are on the way which is amazing I don't
care what kind of a mood you're in you
should be in a better mood now right
mrs. fields calm promo code should be or
get 20% off any gift I mean that's good
stuff alrighty so we've had some
experience with the wealth tax and the
wealth tax has been tried before was
tried in France it was a giant failed
David Andelman wrote for CNN about
42,000 millionaires left France between
2000 and 2014 according to the financial
paper
les echos many of them to camp to other
countries like Belgium or Portugal which
boasts a flat tax of just 28% on income
from interest in investment for
expatriates and no wealth tax Eugenio
Carrara a French accountant pointed out
to me that an estimated 15,000 French
expatriates have taken up residence in
Portugal many of them eager to flee the
French tax system one French tax
consultant Eric pinche estimated that
the wealth tax earned the government
some 2.6 billion dollars a year but
across more than 125 billion dollars in
capital flight every single year from
1998 to 2006 because if you're rich you
know you can afford to do move you can't
know the way that Elizabeth Warren
intends on stopping this if she intends
on grabbing like 40 percent of your
total wealth if you try to move which by
the way you're now creating an economic
berlin wall we are actually gonna
confiscate your wealth if you leave
that's how you know you're running a
crappy economy is when you're saying to
people and if you try to leave we're
gonna grab all your wealth
yeah that's that's pretty terrible stuff
you know like this was this is the
policy generally of dictatorships it
when dictatorships try to confiscate
everybody's wealth and then they're like
okay and if you leave
we're gonna grab all your crap and
you're not gonna take any of it with you
it's bad stuff that's bad by the way if
you think billionaires can't see this
coming you are wrong
hey if Elizabeth Warren is elected
people will move the next day not like a
year from now now two years from now
it'll all do it like now because they
will figure the chances that Elizabeth
Warren passes this sort of thing are not
horrible now it is unconstitutional I
mean it is worth noting that the wealth
tax is unconstitutional right the
sixteenth Amendment specifically allows
the income tax but the fact is that
article 1 section 9 of the Constitution
says that no no capitation or other
direct tax shall be laid unless in
proportion to the census or enumeration
herein before directed to be taken in
other words if 30 percent of the
population lives in New York 30 percent
of the 30 percent of the tax money is
supposed to come from the state of New
York under the original Constitution the
income tax was an explicit exception and
that was passed in the sixteenth
amendment one of the worst Republicans
move in history by the way the sixteenth
amendment only passes because
Republicans want tariffs so they traded
to the Democrats you get Tara will get
tariffs and you get the income tax ah
the worst I mean just the worst deal
since the trade of Lou Brock it's just
it's just the worst deal ever Wow hey
but here's here's the big problem
putting all of that aside you think that
rich people aren't gonna leave get a
study by the Organisation for Economic
Cooperation and Development found that
past attempts to tax wealth quote
frequently failed to meet the
redistribute of goals and encountered
significant administrative problems and
again the people who are most
disadvantaged by this are actually not
the people who are the people who own
massive publicly traded companies like
Zuckerberg or gates or Bezos the people
who really get screwed are the people
who are the people who own active
businesses that are not publicly traded
because then your business is assessed
every single year and you can't defray
the costs eat through public ownership
meaning right now Jeff Bezos doesn't pay
all the bills the the investors the
shareholders pay all the bills but if
you are the sole owner of a large
business then you pay all the bills you
may not take a profit this year you may
take a loss this year and you're still
paying an exorbitant wealth tax I'm the
quote unquote value of the business so
what is this really about it's very easy
this is really about class warfare it's
really about Elizabeth Warren playing
this game or she pretends that the rich
people are the villains in our society
and it's disgusting I'm sorry it truly
is Mark Cuban slammed Elizabeth Warren
well he should the owner of the Dallas
Mavericks had a whole tweet storm about
Elizabeth Warren he said the reality for
Elizabeth Warren is that this is as much
to divert attention from her income and
net worth than anything else other than
steyr she's the wealthiest of all the
Democratic candidates by far it's
amazing by the way that nobody's
pointing this out how is it that we are
now eight months into the Elizabeth
Warren campaign and nobody has pointed
out that she's worth 12 million dollars
she is worth twelve million dollars he's
for all the rich people are ruining the
earth okay the difference between some
people were twelve million dollars is
that they've created a bunch of jobs
Elizabeth Warren has not created a job
so far as I'm aware other than the job
that she created at Harvard Law Firm
herself by falsely claiming she was
Native American allegedly Cuban says
according to her filings she made nine
hundred thousand dollars last year which
means her family earns more than two
times the amount needed to be a
one-percenter she paid twenty five point
five percent of that in taxes which is
less than the percentage I paid in taxes
twenty nine point eight five percent by
the way that's because Mark Cuban is
making some money off of his capital
income investment in fact is that I am
last I checked I think last year I paid
a forty eight percent effective tax rate
Mark Cuban says Forbes says her net
worth is north of twelve million dollars
that's being rich filthy rich
I'm sure it's richer than she ever
imagined she would be good for her she
earned it it puts her millions above the
threshold for being part of the richest
1% by a net worth in our country and
that is 100 percent right okay Mark
Cuban is correct the fact that the fact
that Elizabeth Warren is misdirecting to
rich people are really bad yeah lady why
don't you take a look in the mirror my
favorite thing though is it I mean that
that is arrogant my favorite thing is
Bernie Sanders in aoc so Bernie Sanders
is now campaigning with aoc he's like
sure I'm very old sure I may be out of
touch but here is a hip young woman
knows hunky guys and ales he's like he's
like a father figure I mean it's really
it's really bizarre like she actually
did a video where she was like I didn't
know my own worth until I saw Bernie
Sanders really you didn't know your own
really that guy like the old socialist
who's never accomplished anything has
been living off taxpayer bucks for his
entire adult life you saw him you're
like oh now I feel a sense of self-worth
now now I feel as though I am really
truly a valuable human okay so for an
exercise in in weird quasi Freudian
bizarro world campaigning here is Bernie
Sanders campaigning alongside aoc with
Bernie Sanders saying the Michael
Bloomberg removed Michael Bloomberg
declared last week Michael Bloomberg is
very bad by the way according to the
left not because of stop-and-frisk or
there's some people with the New York
Times who don't like him over
stop-and-frisk but the real reason
Michael Bloomberg is bad is cuz he's a
billionaire and we know billionaires are
very bad the New York Times is saying
this today also the New York Times has
an entire piece today from Michael to
mask I'll get to in a second talking
about how billionaires are the worst
among us I don't know when they
transformed into being the worst right
they were okay before like they're the
same person when they were making 50
grand living and living in the garage
and putting out of the business now
they're just real rich
apparently there's I've always been
looking for this from the left where is
the dollar threshold where you cross
over from being a person who's striving
to make it to being an evil wealthy
person where is that dollar threshold is
it like when you make more than a
hundred thousand dollars a year to get
to a hundred thousand and one dollars
and then boom
Satan grabs you and suddenly you are
inhabited by the spirit of the demon and
suddenly you just hate everyone what a
fire everyone you're a rapacious
capitalist who pollutes the river it's a
very stupid and puerile sense of what
human nature is but in any case here's
Bernie Sanders blasting Michael
Bloomberg saying that it's arrogant for
him to run you can't buy this election
Michael Bloomberg I love the Bernie
Sanders's it's arrogant okay I'm just
gonna point this out Bernie Sanders has
not accomplished a thing one like zero
things does he accomplished his entire
life anything he's not passed a single
major bill he has not been behind a
single major initiative that has passed
in anyway he's been wrong on nearly
everything is adult life when he wasn't
campaigning shirtless in the USSR he was
backing the Venezuelans I mean like he
there is nothing Bernie Sanders has done
that is worthy of praise and yet he is a
leading presidential candidate and he's
working on Michael Bloomberg like I in a
Bloomberg fan man I think I wanted to
take away soda and he had all these
regulations about cigarettes and he had
all of this this crazy big government
nonsense but at least Bloomberg has
achieved something in his life for
Bernie Sanders say I should I should run
the country on the basis of never having
accomplished anything and he's like
Michael Bloomberg he's a very arrogant
man how dare he run just because he has
money well Michael Bloomberg has
actually done a thing or two you've done
nothing except be old and ranted the
moon your entire career and when he was
30 he was old ranting at the moon here's
here's Bernie Sanders ripping into
Michael Bloomberg with AOC at his side
to provide him the hit be uncover
because she can dance
he's considering entering this race is
because he doesn't think anyone can do
the job that is currently in the field
not even you not even well you know that
is the arrogance of billionaires you see
when you're worth fifty billion dollars
I guess you don't have to have town
meetings you don't have to talk to
ordinary people what you do is you take
out I guess a couple of billion dollars
and you buy the state of California but
I happen to believe the American people
are sick and tired of the power and
arrogance of a billionaire class which
increasingly controls not only the
economic life for this country but the
political life for this company power
and arrogance of the billionaire class
AOC has accomplished zero things in her
life aside from getting elected to
Congress in a pure blue district that is
Nancy Pelosi said a bag of crap with a D
on it could have gotten elected in that
district Bernie Sanders has accomplished
zero things in his life and he says it's
the powerful billionaires he wants to
run a government that controls nearly
every aspect of your life in taxes the
living hell out of you
but it's Bloomberg who's arrogant now
listen I don't think that Bloomberg has
a lack of ego but again at least
Bloomberg can make the case he's done a
thing like aa thing and yet the idea
that career government bureaucrat
employees who've never accomplished
anything that these are the people who
are not arrogant they've devoted their
life to public service Bernie Sanders
has devoted his life to living on the
dole to living on the taxpayer dole in
Vermont real difficult life for you
there Bernie thank you for accomplishing
zero things in creating zero jobs don't
worry he's gonna create he says
according to the green new deal twenty
million new jobs
he's never created a job but he's gonna
create 20 million new ones he'll by
confiscating wealth from the people who
actually are responsible for having that
wealth by creating jobs in a second I'm
gonna get deeper into the attack on
billionaires and again I don't think
billionaires are an actual quote unquote
class of people because I don't class
people by income I think there are good
people and they're bad people some are
rich some are poor I don't think that
the amount of money in your wallet makes
you a bad person or a good person I
think there are some billionaires who
are just complete terrible people and I
think there's some billionaires who are
wonderful people I think this idea to
classify all billionaires as among the
people who are trying to control a
country and trying to ruin your life all
of that is robes Pierre garbage it's
just French revolutionary take them out
in the street and behead him garbage
it's nonsense it's just ridiculous but
this is what the entire Democratic Party
apparent
is now gonna buy into you because it's
very convenient to condemn all the
people who actually hire a huge
percentage of the people in this country
in a second you know you keep saying why
are you defending billionaires what what
what do you have in it why are you
defending billionaires the reason I'm
defending billionaires is because the
reason that a lot of billionaires are
billionaires not people who inherited
wealth the vast majority of people who
are billionaires are people core
billionaires because they created
businesses and hundreds of thousands if
not millions of jobs I'll explain in
just one second first let's talk about
how you can manage your families online
time so you know the fact is that you
should set limits on how much your kids
are interacting with screens I've been a
bunch of new studies out recently
showing that small kids interacting the
screens really bad in my house until
your two years of age you don't get to
interact with screens at all even I'll
if I'm a parent and that means that
sometimes the kids are just making
trouble and you sometimes feel like okay
I got to plop them down in front of a TV
and let them watch True on Netflix for a
second just that just to get a break but
the fact is as your kids get older you
don't actually have control over their
screen time as much as you do when they
are young kids and this is why you
should have circle with circle home plus
and circle app parents can filter what
content is allowed set limits for screen
time and monitor history and usage you
can keep track across every connected
device from laptops phones and tablets
to Smart TVs streaming devices and video
game consoles all from one app each
family member has a profile that is
fully customizable to their needs age
and maturity you'll never stop worrying
about your kids but the circle you'll
have one less thing to worry about right
now our listeners get 30 bucks off a
circle home plus when you visit meet
circle comm slash banana tree banan
check out there's a significant link
between kids having a lot of screen time
and being unhappy having other problems
in their social life acts as a material
they shouldn't help stop all of that
with circle get 30 bucks off when you
visit meet circle comm slash Penn and
enter Ben at checkout
that's meet circle comm slash man enter
Ben to save 30 bucks at checkout again
meet circle comm slash Ben okay so
there's the the Bernie Sanders attack on
billionaires in the Elizabeth Warren
attack on billionaires as cynical and
just disgusting and it really is
disgusting it is I'm sorry Elizabeth
Laurens with twelve million dollars and
there's just like.he switch people these
rich people they must be stopped and
then he got Bernie Sanders who is
basically a giant welfare queen living
off the government for the last thirty
what is he now he's 78 years old living
off the government for 50 years of his
life and he's like oh well you know we
couldn't pull any of these people
actually under well
anything they shouldn't run for office
only I should I've been useless my
entire life so useless I was kicked off
a commune
she got Bernie reppin into billionaires
and then he got Michael to masky over at
New York Times saying Bill Gates
I implore you to connect some dots he
says the billionaire class has begun
unloading on Elizabeth Warren you see
it's a class now it's a class now just
to recognize a fact Bill Gates is
basically a lifelong Democrat Warren
Buffett is a lifelong Democrat hey a lot
of these quote unquote billionaire class
members our lifelong Democrats people
who have given tons of money to
left-leaning causes but they're our
class now you see this is pure Marxist
speak where you're judged by the basis
of your income by the basis of your
wealth not by what you think or what you
do or how you vote or any of that sort
of stuff like George Soros is a
billionaire George Soros gives a lot of
money to exactly the kinds of people
that Jamie Dimon doesn't like so
treating everybody as a class based on
their income is really stupid in any
case this this dumb columnist for The
New York Times says the billionaire
class has begun unloading on Elizabeth
Warren a few days ago Jamie Dimon of
JPMorgan Chase at just one point six
billion dollars in net worth a
comparative said senator Moore and
vilifies successful people which is true
then Bill Gates 107 billion dollars in
an on-stage interview with The Times
Andrew Ross Sorkin mused about what his
tax bill might be in a Warren presidency
and left the door open to voting for
Trump should Democrats nominate woman
which makes sense because her wolf tax
proposal is bat bleep loony and then
Michael Bloomberg fifty two billion
dollars who had previously criticized
Warren as anti corporate signaled his
intention to jump into the race
obviously out of concern at her eyes I'm
not expert enough to judge the wisdom of
Senator Warren's proposed wealth tax
well then what are you writing about
like this entire thing is about her
wealth tax as I know there are questions
about its constitutionality and that
several European nations tried a similar
approach and founded unworkable though
four countries still have it
I don't get why the candidates aren't
simply proposing to increase marginal
income tax rates on dollars earned above
some very high figure that seems a lot
more straightforward to me the reason
the ignorant the stunning ignorance of
New York Times columnist the reason not
to justify Elizabeth Warren the reason
she's proposing a wealth tax is there
isn't enough money at the upper end of
the income bracket in terms of income on
every year to pay for her proposals the
wealth tax is a confiscatory
nasty tax designed to pay for her
garbage proposals that amount to fifty
two trillion dollars in spending over
the next ten years that's why she's
going for
well tax hey you can increase the
marginal tax rate and can pay for this
stuff it isn't but this guy says this
column is not a brief for mr. Warren's
wealth tax her for her candidacy I don't
have a preferred candidate instead I
want to make a simple plea to the
country's billionaires multi-billion
dollar fortunes are often called
excessive and decadent but here's
something they're rarely called but
ought to be anti-democratic these
fortunes will destroy our democracy so
let me get this straight you aren't a
billion dollars because you have a bunch
of consensual economic transactions of
people and that's anti-democratic what
is it democratic is for the government
to come and seize the results of those
voluntary transactions Jeff Bezos has
not seized wealth from anyone but you
want the government to do that who's
more anti-democratic hey Bill Gates has
not seized wealth from anyone in fact
he's provided jobs to hundreds of
thousands of people and indirectly to
probably millions of people you want to
seize the wealthy has earned on the
basis of those voluntary economic
transactions who's more anti-democratic
you or Bill Gates this guy says why is
it anti-democratic why would it matter
to our democracy whether Jeff Bezos is
worth a hundred and thirteen billion
dollars or thirteen billion dollars
because any democracy needs it robust
and thriving middle class and we've
spent the last 30 years or so
transferring trillions of dollars from
the middle class to the people at the
very top and then he just quotes the
favorite Elizabeth Warren economist
gabriel zucman the 400 richest americans
now own more of the country's riches
than 150 million adults in the bottom
60% of the wealth distribution the 400s
share has tripled since the 1980s well
what happened to people at the bottom
are they all getting poorer no it turns
out that the middle class is getting
richer too by statistics the middle
class has largely become upper middle
class this notion that it's only people
at the top who are living better I love
the sort of hazy that these sort of hazy
sepia tone vision of the 1950s where
every man was a king and every man was
wealthy well first of all you leaving
out a lot of black folks okay so you're
gonna start with the 1950s and the
economy of the 1950s you should
recognize there was a permanent
underclass created by segregation in the
south then and it not having to do with
the qualities of black people having me
do it the racism of white people in the
1950 South so those two things are
somewhat intertwined also you're gonna
have to point out one of the reasons
that the American economy was a
full-employment economy in the 1950s is
because the rest of the world was
literally destroyed in World War two by
the 1960s and 70s when the rest of the
world was catching up on America
unemployment started to rise so and a
comparative level that's real and then
look at the lives of people in the 1950s
it's so funny to hear all of these
people who are professors at Berkeley
talk about how wonderful jobs were in
the nineteen fifties really would you
like to go into rivet for twelve hours a
day is that your idea of a good time we
talked about these office job you live
in you're in an air-conditioned office
and you know you you might get sciatica
from that chair you might get sciatica
from it we have a three point six
percent unemployment rate in this
country by the way which is the lowest
it has been it's it's full employment
economy we have more job openings than
people who are seeking the jobs at this
point hey but your idea is that 1950s
yet a union job and used to go into the
Ford factory and rivet all day that
sound like a great job to you
yeah it's cuz you never done any
riveting it's a really rough job it's a
really really hard job it is a
back-breaking job and yet the idea is
that the 50s were somehow better than
they are now then then we are now
economically really then why does
everybody have an air-conditioner why
does everybody have a TV why does
everybody have a car why does everybody
have a microwave I'm talking about
people under the poverty line okay this
is it's just a perverse view of how the
American economy works but the idea is
that that people in the middle class are
repulsed by great wealth wealth has
shifted to the top it has been taken
away from the middle class there is no
evidence this is true there is zero
evidence that the wealth coming at the
top is coming from the middle class
because that is not how economics works
do you believe that the rich how did the
rich people get the well from middle
class explain it really explain how that
transition happen did they go to
middle-class families put a gun in their
face and say turn over those bucks is
that what Bill Gates did or did he offer
our products a lot of middle-class
people bought and then use to make their
lives better how many of the people that
this dolt I'm sure that he wrote this
thing on some version of Microsoft Word
and so so all of this is just a rip on
billionaires but the fact is
billionaires are billionaires because
they created voluntary economic
transactions they did and when you rip
on quote-unquote big companies in the
United States recognize that you are
ripping on the companies that provide a
plurality of employment in the United
States according to the New York State
Society of Certified Public Accountants
quoting The Wall Street Journal thirty
eight point thirty six point sent this
be it before the before 2008 using
census data the Wall Street Journal
calculated that thirty six point two
percent of people worked at either a
large come
or a very large company large would be
at least 2500 employees very large would
be 10,000 people or more versus 38.9% of
people who worked for small companies
and 24.9%
who worked for mid-sized companies hey
even a mid-sized companies a pretty
large company 100 employees or more so
daily wired would classify probably as a
midsize company since 2014 the latest
year for which there are census data
according to again the CPAs of New York
this is no longer the case at this point
thirty nine point two percent of
Americans are employed at either a large
or a very large company while 26.5%
works at mid-sized companies and thirty
four point three percent worked at small
companies so that means consolidation
big companies they're hiring you and you
know who tends to own rich companies or
big portions of rich companies big
companies billionaires you know why
because the company's successful it
we're gonna get more into this in just
one second because the vilification of
wealth in this country is insane
counterproductive and stupid and by the
way it's a violation of the tenth
commandment by if you're just gonna go
into moral level it's a violation of the
10th amendment you shouldn't covet your
neighbor's property for you to suggest
that Bill Gates has wealth must be taken
away from him on the basis that you
don't like Bill Gates being wealthy
that's you being a bad person it is I'm
sorry if it's about your jealousy level
it's you and I hear from people in left
well if you could just take 1 billion
away from Bill Gates and heal
homelessness wouldn't you do it first of
all you're assuming two things one that
if a homeless person breaks into Bill
Gates's house and steals a billion
dollars that somehow that's morally
acceptable which it is not to that you
can solve the homelessness problem by
throwing money at it which I think that
Los Angeles New York and San Francisco
have proved how stupid that idea is ok
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let's talk about you saving
time and money in your own life
stamps.com they bring all the services
of the US Postal Service directly to
your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps calm can handle it all with
ease you simply use your computer
difference of prints official US postage
24/7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
it once your mail is ready just hand it
to that mail carrier or drop it in a
mailbox it's incredibly simple it's no
wonder over 700,000 small business is
already used stamps calm and with stamps
calm you get five cents off every
first-class stamp in up to 40% off
Priority Mail and you don't have to go
to the post office like I like the post
office it's great lots of services last
time I
got a parking ticket you gotta wait in
line yeah it's an expenditure of time
that you just can't afford if you're
running a small business go check out
stamps.com
right now especially during holiday
season when you don't feel like slapping
those packages now into the post office
there is no risk with my promo code
Shapiro you get a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale no long term
commitments or contracts using our code
you'll be saving money and supporting
the show go to stamps com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in at Shapiro that is stamps comm
enter Shapiro stamps comm and never go
to the post office again okay in just a
second we're gonna get to more of the
attack on success in this country which
is really what this is about we're gonna
get to that in just a second first if
you're not already a subscriber you are
missing out head on over to daily
wire.com slash subscribe for as little
as 10 bucks a month you get our articles
ad free access to all of our live
broadcasts our full show library select
bonus content and our exclusive daily
water app which is a pretty great
feature if you haven't checked it out
yet if you choose the new All Access
plan you'll get all of that plus the
legendary leftist here's tumblr woo ah
and our brand-new ask me anything style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage our hosts writers and special
guests on a weekly basis so stop
depriving yourself come join the fun
over at daily wire comm we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
you
okay a few more stats for you okay with
regard to billionaires the evil evil
billionaires who are ruining your life
in controlling democracy supposedly
first of all I'm confused if
billionaires are controlling our
democracy then why is Elizabeth Warren
and Bernie Sant why are they doing well
in these primaries shouldn't it be like
Michael Bloomberg doing amazing in the
primaries you shouldn't Tom Steyer just
be dominating the primaries I'm
constantly confused by the ideas that
the the idea that billionaires run our
political system when in fact major
unions outspent billionaires regularly
when the fact is that billionaires are
not the ones who are actually Donald
Trump did not there plenty of
billionaires we're giving money in the
2016 election cycle in the primaries
none of them gave money to Trump so far
as I'm aware money is not what's in
control if the media are basic your
control the media is basically what the
test is at this point and media members
who are benefitting by the way from
billionaires like Carlos Slim owning the
New York Times and then cashing the
check from Carlos Slim it is it is
definitely of benefit to them that a
billionaire owns the New York Times in
any case there's this weird idea that
billionaires don't actually create jobs
they're just taking that money and
sucking it away there's only one problem
first of all how you define billionaire
is basically in medicate like Jeff Bezos
he doesn't have a hundred billion
dollars in cash he has stock in Amazon
and as he provides goods and services to
people that stock rises or Falls that's
why you'll see headlines like Mark
Zuckerberg lost a billion dollars in a
day no I didn't lose any money that day
his stock prices went down if he sold
that day he'd lose the money he didn't
lose any money cuz didn't sell the stock
hey same thing with Jeff Bezos so just
understand that when you're talking
about somebody's wealth we're talking
about somebody's wealth you're talking
about not just cash assets and in case
I'm the the idea that billionaires have
not created jobs that somehow they're
the ones who are our problem that Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren who have not
created so far as I'm aware a single job
in the history of their employment not
one right Bernie Sanders his jobs have
all been created by staff or by
campaigns hey Elizabeth Warren she had
some aids paid for by Harvard Law School
and maybe some teacher's assistants
that's pretty much it and that but they
but they know how to create jobs they
are the great job creators you know it's
so funny Elizabeth Warren was one of the
leaders in the you didn't build that
routine and she was the one who came up
with that she ends of all Patrick I
think in Massachusetts I think she was
the first one to use it and Obama
hi jacket that you didn't build that you
if you built something it was created by
the people who created roads yes because
it was the road that made Amazon happen
yes it is obvious that using public
resources is one aspect of living in a
large Republic it is also true that you
know what didn't create Amazon at the
road okay that would be necessary but
not sufficient there you're missing a
large element called Amazon in that
particular wait it's so funny to meet
people in from the government telling
you you didn't you didn't build that you
know who really didn't build that the
members of the government they didn't
they provided you with a necessary piece
that in all likelihood you probably
could have come up with in coordination
with others we've been more expensive in
many cases but the notion that you the
proper response say you didn't build
that is no you didn't build that unit
elizabeth warren has built nothing
nothing so far as I'm aware Bernie
Sanders has built zero things ever and
yet we're being told you didn't build
that who who is you because if this is a
comparative if this is comparative thing
if you want to say look let's try it
ballpark this thing if you're saying
that it's roads and firefighters and
police and because those things exist
you can have a company in the United
States and then so you didn't build that
let's try to ballpark the percentage
responsibility for building a business
yeah you're right
without the road without the police not
the firefighters be difficult to build a
business absolutely correct you know
what percentage of building a business
that represents I don't know what do you
think two percent three percent sure
ain't sixty nine hundred a rule of law
is necessary but not sufficient
people have to create businesses off the
top of that and so the idea that you're
gonna be paying exorbitant levels of
money to the government for roads is
that going for roads we know it's not
going for roads so stop pretending even
if you want to make the case you didn't
build that
and it was the roads and was the police
and the firefighters fine you know what
that would represent in terms of the tax
rate like nothing like close to zero to
pay for those things they supposedly
contributed to you building the business
I'll tell you what didn't build the
business welfare dollars typically
Social Security didn't build the
business Medicare Medicaid didn't build
the business now you wanna make the case
for those things go ahead and make that
case but don't make the case that you
owe the money for Social Security
Medicare and Medicaid because
quote-unquote you didn't build that
that's that's absolute it there's no but
it's a complete
sequitur the two things have nothing to
do with one another okay in any case how
many jobs are quote-unquote billionaires
in the United States creating Lauren
Karen blank failed over at Forbes com
the top 12 billionaires in America as of
October 2016 had created a minimum of
2.3 million jobs a top 12 that's a lot
of jobs guys a lot of jobs 2.3 million
and that is just direct jobs people who
directly work for their companies have
you know anything about economics you
also understand that they've created a
lot more indirect jobs so for example
Bernie Marcus and Arthur Blank were
fired from their jobs at a hardware
store in 1978 then they opened Home
Depot today Home Depot has more than
385,000 workers in the united states
canada and mexico but let's be real
about this home depot provides a lot
more jobs than that indirectly because
they provide all sorts of great products
at great prices
how many plumbers and handymen and can
and contractors and construction workers
and real estate moguls have made their
fortune based on the fact that they get
to use materials that are brought to
them by those three hundred eighty-five
thousand workers at Home Depot the
economy is interconnected you hear the
same complaint about like Mark
Zuckerberg over at Facebook or Google
because there are only about 15,000 jobs
at Facebook or 40,000 jobs at Google
right but how many businesses are
reliant on Facebook or Google in order
to do their business the entire media is
reliant on Google
that's tens of thousands of jobs the
entire media many practical businesses
are reliant on Facebook to get out the
word about their businesses these are
value-added propositions so why are you
angry at value-added propositions and
then you're angry again you're gonna
have to explain to me how Mark
Zuckerberg seized his wealth from middle
class you're gonna have to explain to me
how Jeff Bezos who's made your life
better in practically every week now we
live in a magical world where you can
hit a button and something arrives at
your door in like two days from anywhere
on earth that's insane and then you're
telling me he's the bad guy here not
Elizabeth Warren who wants to confiscate
his wealth and yours by the way that
Bernie Sanders isn't the bad guy a
lifelong leech who's accomplished
nothing that he that he's he's he's not
the bad guy that Jeff Bezos is the bad
guy and spare me spare me this routine
gets real old real quick okay speaking
of the media defending Elizabeth Warren
it is pretty incredible
the media continue to defend Elizabeth
Warren no matter what and the way they
are defending her is of course claiming
wait for it wait for it any attacks on
her are sexist if you point out that
Elizabeth Warren is worth 12 million
dollars that her policy proposals are
garbage that they don't hold together
that she's intellectually dishonest that
she switched nearly every position she
ever held and that she has lied
repeatedly about her past it's because
you're sexist if you point out that she
campaigns on anger and that she is
divisive and nasty then this is
apparently a reflection of your sexism
because I would never say anything like
divisive nasty combative crap proposals
about somebody like Bernie Sanders oh
wait I just did cuz he is but apparently
if you say it about Elizabeth Warren
you're a sexist natural he's in the New
York Times rushing to Elizabeth Warren's
defense with all the all the chivalry
required to defend a woman they have a
piece today titled Biden's attacks on
Warren turned personal drawing some
complaints of sexism
oh you mean people are complaining
that's news I love when that is one of
my favorite tricks to the media is when
they say some complain of X right who
are these some would they work for the
war in campaign perhaps or maybe it's
you maybe it's you maybe when you say
some it's you it's funny Trump well
sometimes do the same thing right you'll
hear President Trump say things like
people are saying people I say and what
it really means is I'm saying but Pepa
who are these people
Pepa right and the media do it they they
ripped from for doing it and then they
do it a thousand times more they'll be
like some say Biden is a sexist were
these some probably the reporters at the
New York Times I would guess because
it's sexist to point out that Elizabeth
Warren is a liar say senator Elizabeth
Warren is instructing voters on what to
believe her policy vision smacks of an
academic exercise her advocacy style is
quote my way or the highway and she has
displayed an elitist attitude in ways
overt and subtle Joe Biden his campaign
and his allies have begun mounting
personal attacks on the most formidable
rival in the twenty twenty primary race
portraying her as embracing a rigid
condescending approach that befits a
former Harvard professor with an
ambitious policy agenda it is a
politically risky case to make against a
leading female cancer ooh ooh she's got
a vagina that means you can't say that
she has a rigid policy approach even
though she has a rigid policy approach
and has suggested that all of her
opponents are not sufficiently are not
sufficiently ambitious I mean obviously
this has to do with the fact that she's
got a couple X
that's real that's that's my Biden's
doing this clearly and then you've got
the and then you've got the Washington
Post trying to pretend that Ayane
Presley endorsing Elizabeth Warren is
some sort of huge thing the Ringo Starr
of the squad ooh I Anna Presley said a
thing Wow
that changes everything according to the
Washington Post last week Elizabeth
Warren picking up endorsement from a
congressional rising star and a new
group composed of black women and gender
non-conforming people wow that has
completely changed the race you mean
that gender non-conforming women of
color are endorsing Elizabeth Warren
online well I don't think all of them I
think mostly it's just like the small
group right now Jana Presley is like a
nobody except that she hangs out with
the squad and kind of hangs on to their
coattails
last I heard of Iona Presley she was
suggesting that that you have to think a
certain way in order to be a proper
Hispanic or a proper Muslim or a proper
or a proper black person was was last I
checked with Hannah Presley apparently
is a very very big move the media
grandstanding in favor of Elizabeth
Warren is pretty astonishing okay I have
to give you the very very brief
impeachment gate 29 update 2019 update
or I have been remiss today so that is
because today begin the public hearings
the public hearings and the media the
media are already calling on themselves
to make sure that they twist this
exactly the way Democrats want to
Margaret Sullavan Sullivan and media
columnist for The Washington Post she
has a piece today titled media beware
impeachment hearings will be the
trickiest test of covering Trump what
she means by that is that you should
never ever suggest that maybe
Republicans have a point yeah be very
careful don't say Democrats say this and
Republicans say this say Democrats say
this and Republicans lie that's mean
that's Margaret at Sullivan's point she
says the National media's shortcomings
have been all too obvious in recent
years as Donald Trump has gleefully
thrown the norms of traditional
journalism into a tizzy
they've trafficked in false equivalence
allowed President Trump to play
assignment editor gotten mired in
pointless pundit REE granted it's been a
mixed record journalists have done a lot
right they've pointed out lies dug out
what's really happening skillfully
explained and analyzed but on Wednesday
has televised impeachment hearings begin
in the House of Representatives
journalists need to be on their game the
stakes don't get much higher when it
comes to fulfilling their core mission
informing citizens of what they really
need to know and what they really need
to know is the Trump needs to be
impeached so stop trying to present both
sides
stop trying to say on the one hand on
the other hand
trying to be objective instead just say
what you want Trump's a liar and he
committed a crime and he should be
impeached that's how the meet you're
gonna cover this thing by the way there
is something delicious about the fact
that even as the media insist that
Democrats have a foolproof case against
President Trump members of the
Democratic Party are saying that hunter
Biden certainly certainly should not be
called the reason Republicans want to
call hunter Biden is they want to point
out that Trump had legit questions about
hunter Biden and Purisima and he got aoc
out front saying I'm all for
transparency but why should hunter Biden
be called he's a nice man
why I don't think he's an appropriate
witness and not only that but I think
that the reason they're calling for
these witnesses these new witnesses is
because they want to make a spectacle
and a circus out of this entire
proceeding they want to distract the
American people these witnesses that
they're calling are politically
motivated Republicans are turning this
into a partisan issue and I'll tell you
if a Democrat did what Donald Trump did
I would be calling for that Democrats
impeachment oh really would you really
would you hmm
I remember her loudly calling for Barack
Obama's impeachment when the IRS started
targeting conservatives I remember that
my favorite thing is that Bernie Sanders
is just facing out there he's just like
think maybe if I think about putting
this interview will be over soon all
righty time for a thing I like and then
a thing I hate
so things that I like over the weekend
you know if you want to have some if you
want to have a good deal of enjoyment
check out the work of Paul Johnson I'm a
big Paul Johnson Fannie's the historian
British historian and he has a really
fun book called humorists about various
sort of humorous figures in in British
and American history and it's it's
really kind of a kick there is a bunch
of short bios of people ranging from
Hogarth to Benjamin Franklin to the Marx
Brothers and it's not necessarily the
names that you would think of these sort
of highfalutin names but it is a lot of
fun there's some good one liners that
you'll be able to quote to your friends
it's kind of a kick so check it out
humorous by Paul Johnson as I say I'm an
appalled johnson kick right now I've
been going through a lot of his work so
this is just the latest in a series
humorist by Paul Johnson go check that
out okay time for a quick thing that I
hate
well the New York Times is on it it's on
it apparently there's a library there's
a library in I in Idaho and it turns out
somebody at the library in Idaho is
hiding the anti-trump books and the New
York Times is on it is a national story
it's in their national section you're
right a library in Idaho some Rando is
switching the books around this it must
be covered by the New York Times now let
me be real about this I've had I've
written what eight nine books I can't
even remember at this point ghost
written so many - I've written a lot of
books I can't tell you the number of
times I will go in a bookstore and
somebody has hidden my book behind
another book it happens a lot it this is
a real thing it happens at bookstores on
a routine basis it happens in libraries
on a routine basis never has this been a
national story but apparently it's a
national story now because someone is
hiding books in Idaho hmm let's get
encyclopedia brown on the case gang
who's hiding the books in Idaho
according to the New York Times from her
office next to the public computer
terminals pet Amman finds herself
peering through a window to watch
patrons moving through the cure D Alene
library's nonfiction stacks someone has
been hiding books lately specifically
those that explore politics through a
progressive lens or a criticize
president Trump they wind up misfiled in
out-of-the-way corners where readers
will not be able to find them Ammon says
the mystery book relocator actually left
a note so this is actually turn it's a
national encyclopedia brown case it's
gonna turn out - maybe it'll turn out to
be like a villain from scooby-doo
I wouldn't got away with it if you
weren't for the one for those darn kids
it's me Ruben Ruben root in any case the
mystery book relocator says I'm the
ghost of the library son I'm going to
continue hiding these books in the most
obscure places I can find to keep this
propaganda out of the hands of young
minds or liberal angst gives me great
pleasure for decades cured Allen has
navigated a delicate political Nance
landscape in northern Idaho a
conservative corner of the country or
someone sought refuge from political and
social changes elsewhere the incidents
over the past year including a missing
book that was discovered only this week
were not the first time books have
mysteriously disappeared
thirty years ago the library lost so
many books on human rights to theft they
had to be placed in a locked cabinet the
latest works to be targeted cover a wide
range of topics from gun control and
women's suffrage to
btq issues and how people have color
fair in the criminal justice system
about half the books specifically deal
with President Trump well none of the
books have appear to have been stolen
some have been hidden in ways that make
it nearly impossible to find them when
patrons wanted to check them out
they've been discovered inexplicably
filed in the wrong sections hidden
behind a row of Stewart Woods novels are
shelved with the spine facing inward
okay so is this a stupid like don't do
this don't hide books at the library
idiots like don't do that it's a bad
thing to do don't do it also this is a
national news story I'm amused to find
that the New York Times which has a city
filled with bookstores where people hide
conservative books I mean this is a
routine complaint I get from fellow
conservative authors they have never
ever like you want to do a full-scale
investigation how about this they should
do an investigation into which books
actually get placed at the front tables
of Barnes & Noble like that actually be
an interesting one right because that
actually makes a lot more difference
then where a book gets filed in Idaho
bookstores across the nation those front
facing tables some publishers will pay a
super fee to get their books up front
but very often it is editorial judgment
of the people managing the bookstores
that decides which books are placed
where and nearly universally those books
are books that represent the left I mean
this is just a thing it's been true for
a very long time I look forward to the
New York Times reporting on this when
they are done finishing the case of who
moved who moved the Al Franken book who
did it New York Times really solid work
there the journalism in we've all been
waiting for our a we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we will see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo wide outski
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Olvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]